[Music]
gez sets the record straight on demi
lovato after rumors of a possible new
romance now she's just a friend
yeah
the 29 year old rapper spoke with et at
the 2018 ESPY Awards where he debuted
his brand-new platinum blonde ooh gee
candidly addressed the growing interest
in his personal life amid his split from
singer Halsey earlier this month
it's just one of those things that comes
with the territory you know it's kind of
you trade in your anonymity in exchange
for some of your success in the public
eye you have to remember the blessings
and I remember you know how grateful you
are to be here in the first place and I
understand that some of that's just what
comes to the I have to say it's very
graceful how you guys handle the
break-up I love that I think it was done
with lots of respect and love
just days before Halsey revealed they
had called it quits gez had nothing but
praise for her she's really yeah she's
really brave she's an amazing person
she's so intelligent so insightful and
so you know just understanding you know
she's a brilliant human I think it would
be such a natural fit to see the two of
you link up for a joint record is that
something you've ever had a conversation
about yeah I think we could do that
pretty easily we were actually in this
videos the other night when we did a
couple records and you know we motivate
each other and we both like we're fans
of each other's music and we have a
similar kind of perspective
aesthetically on creating music so we
play off of each other well
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]